Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass Ligatour, Ausgabe Nummer 3. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League, La Liga, die Ligue 1 und die Serie A. Hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 184. Und ich freue mich sehr, eine große Runde begrüßen zu dürfen, inklusive eines Neuzugangs. Den heben wir uns natürlich zum Schluss auf. Ich begrüße zu meiner Linken, er ist in die Rasenfunk Headquarters gekommen. Christian Bernhardt, hallo Christian.
Hallo Max, hallo in die Runde.
Ich begrüße zugeschaltet Nils Kärn, hallo Nils. Sehr gut und ebenfalls hier, how are you? Jogi Hebel für die Premier League. Das war cringe, hallo Jogi. Ja, ja, ja, genau. Sagt der, der Jürgen Klopp interviewt. Gut, wobei das ging natürlich, das war ein schlechtes Beispiel. Der Max ist schon auf Hochtouren, wie gut, das passt ja auch wunderbar jetzt dann zu einem neuen Gast, den wir haben. Dem zeige ich mich dann gleich von meiner besten Seite. Ich freue mich sehr, dass Alexis Menuge hier ist. Ihr kennt ihn natürlich aus dem Sportradio 360, vielleicht auch von der Saunen. Hallo, Alexis. Ja, sehr schön, dass wir dich hier für den Rasenfunk gewinnen konnten. Wir haben uns ein bisschen Gedanken über dieses Format gemacht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und wir werden das in Zukunft so machen, die Reihenfolge der Ligen, über die wir sprechen, ist nicht von vorher klar, sondern ich gebe den Imperator. Und jeder muss jetzt ein Plädoyer halten, mit welcher Liga wir anfangen. Nils, du darfst mal vorlegen, warum war das, was in der La Liga passiert ist, in der spanischen Liga das Wichtigste?
Ich würde gern sagen, dass es geplant war, purer Zufall.
Ja, bestimmt, bestimmt. Das hat verschiedene Gründe. Einerseits hat La Liga viele Talente in den letzten Jahren verloren. Da freut sich speziell der Jogi drüber. Ferran Torres, Marco Correa, Brian Hill, Sergio Reguilón, die spielen in der Premier League. Auch Superstars wie Neymar, Ronaldo, Messi, Ramos haben ja nicht nur für Spektakel, sondern auch einige Tore gesorgt. Es wurde am wenigsten ausgegeben im Sommer im Vergleich zu den anderen Top-Ligen. Man hat im Schnitt die ältesten Spieler in La Liga. Ja, und irgendwie die große Zeit scheint so vorbei, wo Real und Barca regelmäßig Champions League gewinnen. Jetzt gab es zwar mal den Europa-League-Sieg von Villarreal, aber trotzdem ist da irgendwie La Liga auf dem absteigenden Ast. Es fallen wenig Tore. Es ist sehr überschaubarer, sehr risikoarmer Fußball. Viele 1-0-Siege, wo lange die 0-0en stehen, da gibt es zwar immer noch ein paar Last-Minute-Tore. Das war zuletzt mal wieder so der Fall. Aber irgendwie ist das oft sehr bieder. Manche Teams haben gerade mal irgendwie sieben Abschlüsse pro Spiel. Das sind Elche, Cádiz, Levante, Granada. Auch die versuchen, mit ganz wenigen einfachen Mitteln Erfolg zu haben, den Punkt erst mal zu halten. Irgendwie kann ich die Rasenfunk-Zuhörer nicht so überzeugen, jetzt regelmäßig La Liga zu schauen. Wobei jetzt nächstes Wochenende Klassico und auch noch Atletico gegen Real Sociedad da auch noch ein spitzes Spiel. Es gibt schon immer mal vereinzelte Gründe.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Frage der Perspektive. Aber diese Torarmut, die ist schon wirklich heftig. 11 von 20 Teams haben weniger als 10 Tore erzielt nach acht bzw. neun gespielten Spielen. Das geht noch ein bisschen auseinander, hast du ja auch schon angesprochen. Da gab es verschobene Spiele unter anderem. Jetzt könnte man ja aber auch die Diskussion aufmachen. Vielleicht hören wir da auch ein bisschen zu sehr den Chefredakteur von realtotal.de sprechen gerade, wenn du sagst, ach, ist das alles auf dem Absteigen. Man könnte doch auch sagen, hey, wir haben Real, aber Sociedad nicht mal dritt auf Rang 1 gerade mit drei Punkten Vorsprung. Wir haben Sevilla auf Rang 3, wir haben Ossasuna auf 5. Dann Weihekano, über die haben wir schon in den letzten Folgen manchmal gesprochen. Könnte man ja auch sagen, endlich mal wieder eine spannende Liga.
Absolut, La Liga hatte ja so gesehen schon im vergangenen Frühjahr den spannendsten Meisterschaftskampf in Europa, nachdem sich dann Frankreich irgendwann verabschiedet hatte, wo wirklich vier Teams theoretische noch Chancen hatten. Und auch aktuell wieder L'Areal ganz oben. Das gab es zwar auch schon in der vergangenen Hinrunde. Da war Real Sociedad schon sechs Spieltage mal auf Platz eins. Also aktuell, dass die Favoriten mal ein bisschen schwächeln, ist ganz normal. Die haben ja auch noch Verletzte, jede Menge bei Barca, bei Real. Atletik noch nicht so richtig in die Spur gefunden. Aber auch die kommen jetzt langsam. Und ja, das nutzen eben andere Teams aus. Rayo Vallecano als der Aufsteiger mit 16 Punkten. Die haben jedes ihrer vier Heimspiele gewonnen. Sind da absolut vielleicht so das Gegenbeispiel von dem, was ich eben gesagt habe, sehr überschaubarer, risikoarmer, biederer Fußball. Die machen einfach Risiko, trauen sich was. Und wenn sie dann doch eins kassieren, dann machen sie trotzdem noch zwei, drei Fonds. Also Heimspiele sind da absolute Festspiele aktuell. Ich war selbst schon dabei, hab Falcao gesehen, wie er getroffen hat und wie er gefeiert wurde. Also Rayo Vallecano macht aktuell mit am meisten Spaß in La Liga. Ist auch sogar noch, wenn man jetzt auf die Formtabelle schaut, die letzten fünf Partien noch ein Pünktchen besser als Real Sociedad. Auch Osasuna da noch mit dabei. Also es gibt natürlich positive Aspekte aus La Liga.
Ich merke aber schon, die möchtest du klein halten. Das wird hier ganz schnell abgefrühstückt. Wie ist denn das generell gerade die Stimmung rund um die Liga interessiert mich? Weil wir hatten jetzt natürlich die große Aufregung. Wir haben auch immer noch, also es ist auch nicht so, dass sich jetzt alles schon beruhigt hätte, weil wir hatten ja nicht nur das Thema Neymar und MVP, was unterschiedlich, äh, entschuldigung Messi und MVP, was unterschiedlich ausgegangen ist, sondern wir hatten ja auch Super League Pläne, die es immer noch gibt. Wir haben da auch Klagen, da geht es auch fröhlich hin und her zwischen UEFA und dem, nicht nur dem spanischen Verband, sondern vor allem ja den jeweiligen Mannschaften. Wird das positiv aufgefasst, dass man gerade wieder mehr andere Mannschaften sieht, die auch Spannung garantieren? Und ich hab gerade das Gefühl, dass es eigentlich bei jedem Spieltag so ist, dass Real und Barca stolpern könnten, weil sie es jetzt auch schon so häufig getan haben. Und das macht ja eigentlich auch was mit dem gesamten Markt, dass man sich denkt, die spielen jetzt in Granada, das muss ich mir jetzt gar nicht angucken, sondern gerade weil sie das spielen, denke ich mir, ja, das schauen wir jetzt mal an.
Ja, das könnte man sich denken. Also Real hat schon drei Spiele nicht gewonnen, Barca schon vier Spiele nicht gewonnen, Atletico auch drei. Da ist schon immer mal stolper Gefahr bei jedem Spiel, eigentlich egal, ob du beim Aufsteiger bist, bei Nullspielst oder zu Hause, wie er Real empfängt. Aber das heißt jetzt trotzdem nicht, dass die Stadien wirklich gefüllt sind. Jetzt war jetzt der erste Spieltag, wo wieder 100 Prozent erlaubt waren in spanischen Stadien. Trotzdem, in Vigo war nicht mal 50 Prozent erreicht, im Camp Nou sowieso nicht. Also da ist einfach auch noch ein bisschen die Euphorie überschaubar, weil einfach auch das Sportliche vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so spektakulär ist, weil natürlich auch Touristen fehlen in Barcelona, in Madrid natürlich. Die Preise hier und da auch teurer sind, später Anstoßzeiten, immer noch Montagsspiele. Jetzt gestern waren es wieder zwei. Also da ist bestimmt die Stimmung noch ein bisschen gedrückt. Aber wenn du jetzt fragst, Thema Super League, da fand ich es auch ganz interessant, was Jogi eben gesagt hat, Thema Investoren. Und in Deutschland da eben sehr schnell viel Kritik, viel Widerstand. Und pauschal erstmal Nein sagen. In Spanien ist da Super League. Jetzt wird auch nicht gleich ad acta gelegt oder gesagt, das wollen wir auf keinen Fall. Also auch da sehen viele diese Monopolstellung von der UEFA, würden da gerne was ändern. Und sehen eben auch, dass Spiele wie der Klassico oder auch, wenn es Bayern gegen Barca ist, wird einfach zehnmal mehr geschaut als so ein Alaves gegen Raio, was irgendwo ja nachvollziehbar ist. Also da ist die Stimmung jetzt generell zu Super League gar nicht so abgelehnt, auch wenn da in den Vorschlägen von Perriss und Co. nicht alles fein war. Aber da ist man jetzt generell nicht so abgeneigt hinsichtlich der Pläne. Und irgendwas soll da ja noch weiterkommen.
Na gut, sowas müsste sich halt auch entwickeln, natürlich. Ich kenne jetzt auch, wenn Osasuna spielt, da kenne ich die Spieler noch nicht so gut. Aber gut, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Ich will jetzt gar nicht die Grundsatzdebatte aufmachen, auch wenn sich die anderen schon mal alle vorbereiten können. Ganz am Schluss möchte ich noch einen ganz kurzen Rumpflug machen, wie sich die Zuschauerzahlen jetzt entwickeln, jetzt wo die Stadion wieder offen sind. Weil sehen wir ja gerade in der Bundesliga, also ich habe jetzt gerade zugeschickt bekommen, wie viele Tickets noch für Dortmund gegen Ingolstadt im DFB-Pokal da sind. Also Leute, wenn ihr noch Bock auf Stadionbesuch habt, gerade kommt man ganz gut ins Westfalen Stadion. Aber das machen wir ganz am Schluss. Dann lassen wir jetzt dann doch über die großen Teams sprechen. Bei Real können wir ja mal beginnen. Drei Punkte Rückstand aktuell. Da ist jetzt noch nichts in den Brunnen gefallen und die Leistungen sind ja auch zwischendurch sehr gut gewesen. Wo liegen jetzt dann trotzdem die Probleme, dass es jetzt dann nur zu einem Unentschieden und einer Niederlage in den letzten beiden Ligaspielen gereicht hat?
Ja, jetzt wettbewerbsübergreifend hat man sogar die letzten drei Partien nicht gewonnen. Also da natürlich die Presse gleich. Das ist schon eine Minikrise bei Real nach einem eigentlich erfolgreichen Saisonstart unter neuem Trainer Carlo Ancelotti ist so ein bisschen das Offensivspektakel zurück. Man stellt mit 22 Toren die beste Offensive in La Liga. Direkt danach übrigens Rayo Vallecano mit 15, auch spektakulär. Also so schlimm ist eigentlich bei Real alles gar nicht. Sie hatten zuletzt ein paar Probleme, das Tor zu finden, dieses Debakel gegen Sheriff Tiraspol. Ja, das kann passieren. 0-0 gegen Real ist jetzt auch nicht so tragisch. Eher jetzt die Niederlage 1-2 bei Aufsteiger Espanol. Die hat schon eher wehgetan, weil die Mannschaft da keine Lösung gefunden hat, irgendwie Tore zu erzielen. Obwohl sie jetzt, es gibt immer mal ein paar Verletzte, aber trotzdem Benzema ist ja trotzdem noch da und der ist nun mal weiter in Überform. Also neun Tore schon in La Liga, sieben Vorlagen. Das ist natürlich der beste Scorer. Aber irgendwie auch mit ihm hat es dagegen den Aufsteiger nicht zum Sieg gereicht. Trotzdem ist da alles noch im grünen Bereich. Also die drei Punkte Rückstand auf Real Sociedad, die sind da. Aber man hat ja auch noch ein Spiel in der Rückhand. Also ist eigentlich alles so, wie erwartet.
Gut, und wie sieht es beim anderen, dritter Verein aus? Bei Atletico, wie ist da die Gemengelage? Gab es ja jetzt mal einen wichtigen Sieg gegen Barcelona. Der ist jetzt allerdings schon eine Weile her. Am 2. Oktober war das.
Genau, weil die jetzt spielfrei eben auch waren am Wochenende. Konnte da Diego Simeone endlich seinen zweiten Ligasieg über Barcelona einfahren? Das war auch hoch verdient so weit. Atletico eben eine spannende Saison, weil die jetzt in einer ganz neuen Rolle sind. Das kennen die gar nicht, die Rolle des Gejagten. Normal sind die ja immer die Jäger. Da haben sie diese Underdog-Rolle auch vergangenen Saison Spieltag für Spieltag eingenommen und am Ende dann verdient die Meisterschaft gewonnen. Jetzt eben da eine neue Rolle. Spannend kann Luis Suárez diese alte Saison noch mal bestätigen, weil letztes Jahr wollte er es wirklich jedem zeigen. Er wurde bei Barcelona vor die Tür gesetzt. Sehr und dankbarer Abschied hat dann einfach noch mal allen gezeigt. Hey, ich hab's immer noch drauf und bin hier einer der besten Mittelstürmer. Der hat jetzt auch schon einige Male getroffen. Und ja, man merkt einfach, bei Atletico wächst weiter was zusammen. Man ist da ja immer noch eine sehr gute Defensive, auch wenn jetzt aktuell Jimenez verletzt war. Das Grießmann-Comeback hat jetzt noch nicht so wirklich funktioniert. João Felix wird jetzt langsam wieder, findet so langsam in die Spur. Also auch Diego Simeone hat hier und da noch einige Baustellen. Aber auch für Atletico sind eigentlich 17 Punkte aus 8 Partien eigentlich voll im grünen Bereich. Besser geht immer, speziell nach der spektakulären Hinrunde vergangenes Jahr. Aber auch Atletico hat da eben Probleme mit den Länderspielen, mit der engen Terminplanung. Und ja, trotzdem ist man da weiter einer der Kandidaten für den Ligatitel, vielleicht mit Real, also die wahrscheinlichsten Kandidaten.
Und was machen wir mit Barca, unserem Sorgenkind der letzten Wochen, der letzten Ausgaben?
Auch Barcelona ist eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm, wie es in den letzten Wochen hieß. Die liegen auf Platz 7, Nils. Ja, aber jetzt pass auf. Man hat aktuell 15 Punkte nach 8 Partien, ohne Messi. Vergangenes Jahr mit Messi waren es nach 8 Partien nur 11 Punkte und sogar noch ein paar Tore weniger. Also ja, es ist sportlich überschaubar, aber es ist nicht ganz so tragisch. Man ist ja trotzdem 2 Punkte hinter Real und Atletico. Hat eben auch noch ein Spiel in der Rückhand. Und jetzt eben Hoffnungsträger Anzufati zurück. Er hat jetzt 2 Tore schon gemacht in der Liga. Traumhaftes Ding eigentlich am Wochenende. Da hat man 0-1-früh gegen Valencia zurückgelegen. Am Ende noch verdient 3-1 gewonnen. Auch Memphis Depay fühlt sich wohl beim FC Barcelona. Hat da schon die Liebe der Fans, hat auch schon seine 6-Tor-Beteiligung. Also es geht schon da einiges zusammen. Wenn man da jetzt noch einen Aguero fit bekommt, der hat jetzt sein Debüt gemacht am Wochenende, dann hat man, hat Ronald Koeman schon mehr Optionen vorne. Defensive immer noch so ein bisschen das Problem. Piquet ein bisschen eingerostet. Eric Garcia hat hier und da auch mal seine Fehlerchen, seinen Platzverweis auch in der Nationalmannschaften jetzt eben noch Araujo verletzt. Aber auch da ist alles gar nicht so tragisch. Ronald Koeman hat da eben auch die Erwartung ein bisschen runtergeschraubt und gemeint, man kann in der Champions League nicht allzu viel erwarten. Mit der Mannschaft ist es nun mal schwierig. Also man hat den Ligatitel jetzt noch nicht komplett abgeschrieben, aber die Fans wissen da, glaube ich, dass man jetzt keine Wunderdinge erwarten kann. Aber ja, aktuell ist die Tabelle einfach noch ein bisschen verwässert durch das, dass die Top-Teams jeweils ein Spiel weniger haben. Und so Teams wie Osasuna, Nuayu, Valle Cano, so viel Spaß, die aktuell auch machen, keine Frage. Die haben eben jetzt auch noch in ihrem bisherigen Spielplan noch keine Top-Teams wirklich gehabt. Also das kommt jetzt in den nächsten Wochen erst. Und wenn sie da auch wirklich gegen Real, Atletico, Barca zumindest vier Pünktchen holen, dann auf jeden Fall haben sie ihren Topsaisonstart bestätigt. Aber so, das wird sich schon alles einpendeln. Und am Ende Real, Atletico, Barca und speziell auch Sevilla werden da weiter oben stehen.
Und bist da jetzt nur du so entspannt? Oder spiegelt das auch die Stimmung vor Ort wieder? Denn du hast ja jetzt so nonchalant erwähnt. In der Champions League läuft es gerade nicht so gut. Ja, das kann man so sagen. Also wir erinnern uns an das 0 zu 3 gegen die Bayern. Es folgte ein 0 zu 3 bei Benfica. Aktuell, logischerweise, Barca damit mit Nullpunktentabellen. Letzter in dieser Gruppe heißt jetzt nicht, dass die sich nicht für die K.o.-Runde qualifizieren. Heißt aber, die müssen jetzt auf jeden Fall gewinnen. Also da ist jetzt ordentlich Druck auf dem Kessel.
Ja, Champions League natürlich nochmal was anderes nach diesen auch zwei eigentlich katastrophalen oder Blamagen schon fast gegen Bayern und Benfica. Da im Endeffekt mein nonchalant, es kommt vielleicht auch daher, dass Ronald Koeman eigentlich gar nicht so sehr wackelt, wie es vielleicht in Medien immer dargestellt wird. Also er hat eben die Erwartungshaltung schon runtergeschraubt. Im Endeffekt hat Präsident Laporta jetzt auch keinen Plan B gehabt, weil er kein anderer Trainer vielleicht verfügbar war oder weil er nicht Koeman noch weiter zahlen wollte und beurlauben wollte. Deswegen wird das irgendwie so weitergehen. Und dadurch, dass jetzt auch in Dembele bald zurückkehrt und dann ist auch bald Araujo wieder dabei, hat da die Mannschaft zumindest wieder ein bisschen mehr Personalauswahl. Petri, wenn der wieder fit ist, Fati sowieso, wenn der bei den 100 Prozent ist. Aber ja, der Druck ist natürlich jetzt da gegen Kiew. Aber ich sag mal so, dadurch, dass man die Bayern in der Gruppe hat, kann man vielleicht auch auf Schützenhilfe hoffen. Also dass Bayern dann ebenso auch Kiew und Benfica abschießt und dass man so dann einfach noch Platz zwei in Anführungszeichen locker erreichen kann. Champions League-Gruppenphase ist ja, ja, man hat zweimal verloren, aber so wirklich, man kann ja auch zwei, drei Spiele in der Gruppenphase verlieren und qualifiziert sich dann trotzdem noch mit neun Punkten. Also real wurde in dieser verrückten Gruppe letztes Jahr gegen Gladbach, Schachtier und Inter wurde noch irgendwie erster am letzten Spieltag, obwohl die auch gegen Schachtier beides verloren haben und gegen Gladbach unentschieden. Also noch ist da lange nicht alles verloren, aber klar, Druck ist da.
Na gut, das ist ja auch mal ganz schön zu sehen, dass aus der Ferne die Feuer dann doch gar nicht so lodernd brennen, wie man das vielleicht gedacht hätte. Als wir in der letzten Ausgabe mit Fabian Pakulat darüber gesprochen haben, welche Teams man sich mal angucken sollte, hat der Valencia, Rayo Vallecano und San Sebastian empfohlen. Wen würdest du denn jetzt mal vorliegend auf dem Stand ein paar Spiele später empfehlen?
Ja, Valencia hatte einen ziemlich guten Saisonstart, aber jetzt aus den letzten fünf Partien auch nur zwei Pünktchen geholt. Rayo ist ein sehr guter Tipp, speziell bei Heimspielen. Die haben alle ihre vier gewonnen. Ich war einmal dabei, das sind Festspiele da. Wenn da noch mal Chaos trifft, dann exkludiert das Campo de Vallecas auf jeden Fall. Real Sociedad auch sehr gut drauf als Tabellenführer natürlich. Da ist es immer spannend. Die haben auch sehr viele Ausfälle. Also Iyara Mendy kennt man natürlich. David Silva hat noch nicht gespielt dieses Jahr. Carlos Fernandez, der Mittelstürmer. Jetzt war sogar Oya Sabal am Wochenende, hat gefehlt. Trotzdem hat sie irgendwie zu einem 1-0-Sieg gereicht. Die hatten dann in ihrem Heimspiel auch noch endlich die Copa del Rey, den Titel, präsentieren können. Also da ist schon immer spannend, wie da Alguacil Spiel für Spiel eine neue L findet, noch einen Plan C findet und es trotzdem zum Erfolg reicht. Und wenn ich noch ein drittes Team nennen müsste, Valencia nicht, würde ich vielleicht sagen Sevilla, weil die einfach auch, oder weil da einfach auch jetzt seit drei Jahren was sehr Gutes zusammenwächst, eine sehr gute Defensive, die haben erst drei Gegentore kassiert in der Liga. Da hat Gylen Lopetegui, leistet ganze Arbeit offensiv, meist überschaubar, das ist dann meistens doch nur so ein abgeklärter, sehr erfahrener 1-0-Sieg. Aber irgendwie ist Sevilla, spielt dann einen sehr professionellen, erfahrenen Fußball, wo andere Mannschaften noch nicht so wirklich ein Mittel gefunden haben, auch wenn die auch schon mal gestolpert sind.
Okay, ich sehe schon, da gibt es so einiges, was man sich dann doch angucken kann. Ich empfehle mal vielleicht den 27. Oktober, da spielt Rayo Vallecano zu Hause gegen Barca. Nach allem, was du gesagt hast, ist das eins dieser Spiele. Das könnte man sich dann doch mal vielleicht zumindest auf einem Bildschirm mit angucken. Dann ganz schnelle Fragerunde. Wir müssen nicht in die Diskussion gehen, aber was mich interessiert, Nies, du darfst dann beginnen. Wie ist denn die Situation mit den Zuschauern? Kommen die denn jetzt schon zurück, wenn sie dürfen?
Sie dürfen, 100 Prozent sind wieder erlaubt. Aber man spürt in Spanien noch sehr ein Respekt, ein bisschen Angst vor Corona, vor den Ansammlungen auf Toiletten beim Einlass, also jetzt im Camp Nou waren es 47.000 von 99.000. Jetzt bei Real Sociedad waren es 31.000 von 39.000. Also es wächst nach und nach, aber es ist nicht so, dass durch die Euphorie jetzt gleich die Stadien bei 100 Prozent gefüllt sind, eben auch durch späte Zeiten, hohe Preise, wenig Tourismus.
Gut, dann machen wir das jetzt genau in der umgedrehten Reihenfolge, wie wir die Ligen besprochen haben. Jetzt müsst ihr alle ganz schnell nachdenken. Jogi ist dann als nächstes dran. Wie ist denn die Situation gerade mit der Zuschauerauslastung in der Premier League?
Also, wenn ich ehrlich bin, habe ich mich damit jetzt noch nicht umgekehrt beschäftigt im Sinne von, dass ich irgendwas gesehen hätte, dass ein Stadion leer geblieben wäre. Also, ich glaube, der Engländer ist da komplett spaßbefreit. Er nimmt das einfach an und ist froh, wieder da zu sein. Und irgendwie sogar habe ich das Gefühl, noch frenetischer als davor, weil man es irgendwie zu schätzen war. Also, mir wäre jetzt nicht bewusst, dass irgendwo ein Stadion leer geblieben wäre oder irgendwo ein Sitz leer geblieben wäre, ganz im Gegenteil.
Alexi, wie ist die Situation in der Ligue 1?
Ja, ein bisschen wie in England. Man hat wieder 100 Prozent Auslastung seit Beginn der Saison. Und wie ich vorher schon erwähnt, sind bei großen Vereinen wie Marseille, wie Paris Saint-Germain, das Stadion immer voll. Es war in Marseille am Sonntag in Anführungszeichen nur gegen Lorient. So gut die Ausverkauf mit 63.000 Zuschauern. Und das wird auch ausverkauft komplett sein natürlich am Sonntag gegen Paris. Und das ist auch eigentlich nur in Monaco nicht voll, aber das war noch nie voll.
Und wie ist es in der Serie A, Christian?
Ja, Italien war am vorsichtigsten, was die Regierungsvorgaben betrifft. Also erst jetzt, am vergangenen Wochenende durften zum ersten Mal 75 Prozent rein. Davor waren es bis jetzt 50 Prozent. Die Clubs machen zwar schon lange Druck und wollen endlich auf diese 100 auch wieder kommen. Womöglich mal schauen, vielleicht könnte das dann auch irgendwann im November so sein. Aber da war schon noch ein bisschen eine Bremse drin, was auch ein Fakt war, gewisse Fan-Gruppen, gewisse Kurven haben gegen die Corona-Maßnahmen auch, fanden das alles andere als gut, sind teilweise ferngeblieben. Aber es ist jetzt, man merkt schon, sehr viel Euphorie. Gerade wenn du dir die Mainländer-Fereine anschaust bei mir, dann ist San Siro richtig gut voll, als so was möglich war. Juve auch, Rom zum Beispiel. Ganz interessant, viele Clubs, dadurch, dass ja bisher nur 50 Prozent erlaubt waren, hatten gar keinen richtigen Abo-Verkauf, weil mit 50 Prozent. Und jetzt geht es so langsam los. Und die Roma hat, glaube ich, innerhalb von wenigen Tagen all die 18.000 aus der Kurva Sud sozusagen einen Mann gebracht. Also es ist schon viel Lust auf Fußball da. Und die Hoffnung, sorry, nochmal bei den Vereinen, ist eben, dass man auch bald auf die 100 Prozent kommen darf.
Gut, dann danke ich euch allen sehr. Deine Stimme hat jetzt Feierabend, zumindest kurzzeitig. Christian, ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei Christian Bernhard, bei Nies Kern, bei Alexis Menuge und bei Jogi Hebel. Danke euch, Viren, das hat große Freude gemacht. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Dann bleibt mir an dieser Stelle nur noch der Hinweis, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, der Rasenfunk ist werbesponsoren und paywallfrei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über eure freiwillige finanzielle Unterstützung. Wie ihr das tun könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und nicht nur wir profitieren davon, sondern auch unsere Gäste, die daraus ein kleines Honorar bekommen. Also, bitte unterstützt uns. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon bis hierhin getan haben. Wir hören uns wieder in einem unserer zahlreichen Formate. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf. Bis bald mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk.